numéro 8 a c'est dommage ce que je veux
surprendre donc dans les terriens du
samedi attire des 104 5 qui recevait la
chanteuse vitaa et café donc une blague
sur la chanteuse vitaa et son débit
proche diam's l'ex rappeuse c'est une
question qui a fait le buzz ce week-end
regardez là et depuis a eu beaucoup de
scandales sur question raciste pas
raciste et après je veux donner mon avis
et c'est évident le plus intéressant du
vallon non on va voir des images on aura
la vie des autres on le sait tirer
indices on aime la polémique et les
questions qui dérangent fidèle à sa
réputation alors qu'il recevait ce week
end sur ces huit la chanteuse vitaa
l'homme en noir n'a pas pu s'empêcher
une petite sortie qui n'a pas plu à tout
le monde
est ce que vous savez si votre amie
diam's a eu le temps d'aller acheter un
à jack de running chez décathlon avant
qu'il soit retiré de la vente en tout
cas on le sait vita est une grande amie
de la chanteuse diam's qui s'est retiré
du devant de la scène il ya quelques
années mettant fin à sa carrière de
chanteuse et se recentrant sur sa vie de
famille dans le même temps la chanteuse
découvrez la religion et s'était
converti à l'islam et c'est en référence
à ce changement de vie que tu irais
redit son attente et une pointe d'humour
une blague qui est loin de faire
l'unanimité sur les réseaux sociaux
alors alors non c'est faux oui mais non
bébé mais c'est évidemment grand manitou
de la télévision je sais qu'il est sur
cette chaîne et que c'est peut-être mal
venu ce que je vais dire à mon disque on
veut dire y joue lui il accepte toutes
les critiques c'est comme ça que je le
connais pour moi là il a clairement
dépassé les bornes
on ne peut pas se moquer de quelqu'un
qui se convertit moi cette blague elle
m'a heurté alors j'imagine diam's et les
gens qui sont convertis je trouve que
c'est très grave ça ne me fait pas rire
sera privée des personnes concernées
mine de rien oui voilà c'est si c'est
sur elle après bien des gens qui sont
pas concernés la vigile et ben justement
parce que j'ai entendu cette blague ce
que j'ai fait alors que j'ai appelé des
gens des proches qui sont musulmans je
vous assure
d'accord je vous assure que ces gens là
sont profondément choquées oui mais
alors est ce que quand vous les avez
appelé voirie a été choqué vous même
vous leur avez posé la question
question tout naturellement sans les
influencer c'est pour moi un dérapage
mais c'est tout simplement de la
stigmatisation des musulmans il faut
arrêter avec ça vous donne mon point de
vue jean-michel magie gilles tu dis
qu'ils sont choqués choqué par quoi
parce que d'abord c'est quoi
qu'est ce qu'il cherche à stigmatiser
comme entité de des musées de quoi nous
quaigy l'économie du mouvement
tu t'énerves somaggio matthieu delormeau
scion conquois ou le show cache tout
d'abord mais s'il devait y avoir chaud
cage pour une foire métrages et de dieu
sait si j'ai tapé sur ce monsieur c'est
son rôle avec ardisson avec avec ben
pardon avec baffie c'est son rôle
et puis arrêtez vous offusquez de toutes
ces sorties donc dans les magasins
décathlon lui demandait ce qu'elle a
acheté web contenant des mesures rôles
toit jeudi avec toi ce 17 août à mathieu
il m'a dit juive
c'est pas un gros mot il a dit musulman
il t'offre un tour confus ce que des
musulmans d'acquérir sur six sites et le
mr maloke il à l'afp
il n'y a pas une âme à séoul l'aspm il
ya pas de lave fait non il ne trouvait
pas drôle et ses choix quand jean-michel
pourquoi c'est isabelle morini bosc
ou alors c'est marrant parce que pendant
des semaines ils ont fait des blagues
sur les catholiques les pédophiles les
prêtres et c'est très bien n'a aucun
moment vous n'avez émis une critique sur
ça et là brusquement parce qu'il fait
cette blague qui n'est pas la meilleure
au monde faut bien le dire mais qui
n'est qu'une blague parmi d'autres et là
brusquement tout le monde monte au
créneau
je trouve qu'il ya une disparité
pardonnez moi qui malencontreusement
vous êtes d'accord et qui n'ont pas du
tout pas du tout d'accord je le prenne
dans ce cas précis c'est que c'est un
contexte qui est compliqué et que tout
ce qui va dans le sens pour remettre de
l'huile sur le feu n'est pas une bonne
idée
il voit la tuile ceci bien sûr que si
vous le savez très bien ils confient
qu'ils sont qui sont tendues qu'il faut
respecter et faut éviter d'alimenter le
foyer et même ses victimes en une blague
moi ça me dérange dans ce conte alors
que la plaque sur les homosexuels pub la
clc même bien sûr et bien c'est légal
homologue syrien à lévis oui mais si
c'était l'espagne après midi en tout cas
d'après ce que tu dis la polémique auto
d'accord accord ne poussant pas d'accord
à 58% et donc sont pas d'accord avec la
polémique aura l'allemagne a pas lieu
d'en bas qui sont d'accord non